welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and nobody cared
who I was until I put on the mask and
now they won't come within 50 feet of me
anyway though the world right now looks
like Gotham City in the Dark Knight
Rises that doesn't mean that Hollywood
isn't still working away and we have
some big updates on the Batman
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing the brand new interview with
Matt Reeves and which he goes over his
inspiration for the film how he views
the character and just a lot of cool
other things that indicate the direction
of the film there may be some spoilers
here itself you want to go into the
movie as blind as possible then I highly
recommend that he turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel to never
miss an update and without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of the Batman okay so Matt
Reeves recently spoke with the Nerdist
in regards to his Amazon show tales from
the loop and his work on the Batman the
interview did go quite in-depth on a lot
of his other projects but the main focus
for this video will be on the Batman
I'll leave a link to the full interview
below if you want to check it out but
there's a lot going on with it
Reeves firstly talked about his approach
to the character and how he tends to go
towards films stating the following
though it seemed like a daunting task I
had to go in with the mindset that I was
going to pitch the variation of Batman
that I would do which was going to have
a humanist bent I had gone in thinking
who knows if they'll have any interest
if they don't then I won't do it and
that'll be okay I was really lucky that
they said yes so from this we can take
that Reeves is really dealing with the
human side of the dog night rather than
perhaps a superhero I definitely think
it's the most interesting way to deal
with the Caped Crusader and seeing how
Nolan dealt with Bruce as opposed to
others showed that the humanity within
Batman is just as interesting as his
nighttime activities Reeves has of
course placed many character studies
throughout his pieces and he often asks
what it means to be human and civilized
nowhere is this more apparent than in
the Planet of the Apes trilogy which
discussed the failings of our species
through showing the actions of the
monkeys who had learned from our
mistakes
Reeves stated that exploring the
humanity of characters is often a
necessity for his work and when
asked to explain this further he stated
it's not even like that's an approach
that I take like it's some kind of idea
of wouldn't it be great
it's sort of the only thing that allows
me to understand how to do it
I can only understand where the camera
goes and how to talk about the story how
to write the story how to talk to the
actors but if i emotionally understand
what it is i have to do it otherwise I'd
be lost some people are incredible
choreographers and they know how to
create an incredible visual dance or all
that kind of stuff I love that kind of
stuff but at the end of the day I have
to understand it emotionally so though
the film will have some action scenes it
doesn't seem like they will be the big
focus even the Apes trilogy did hold
back on being laced with hundreds of
action set pieces and films like let me
in by Reeves were tone back on climactic
showdowns so it does seem at the very
least that the avenue for the film will
be more driven towards exploring
characters in their arcs rather than
having Batman punching hundreds of
people in the face it's good to see him
doing some social distancing we do know
that the film will be based on the
graphic novel along Halloween and that
isn't an action comic book instead it
lays the focus on a mysterious killer
within Gotham and the investigation that
leads to their capture so it is likely
that Reeves is following this instead
when asked what aspect of a brand new
Batman that he was most excited about
exploring Reeve stated I wanted to do
not an origin tale but a tale that would
still acknowledge his origins in that it
formed who he is like this guy he's
majorly struggling and this is how he's
trying to rise above that struggle but
that doesn't mean that he even fully
understands you know it's that whole
idea of the shadow self and what's
driving you and how much of that you can
incorporate and how much of it that
you're doing that you're completely
unaware of so it doesn't seem like we're
gonna be getting the wayans shot in
Crime Alley again and again and again or
even the events that led up to it I
doubt they will show cases full training
and there may not be many things set in
Bruce's young years at the moment we
haven't seen any casting information for
a young Bruce however it does son like
Reeves at the very least will be
showcasing elements from Bruce's past I
would absolutely love to see a montage
similar to the one that we got
the trailer for arkham origins which
quickly flicked through bruce's life and
also gave us some of the defining
moments from his past hope this is the
case as though we don't need a complete
origin story with this being a brand new
Batman it would be nice to at least have
some details from his past filled in
reves finished the interview by saying
there's something in there that feels
very psychological very emotional and it
felt like there was a way of exploring
that along with the corruption in this
place Gotham that feels very current I
think it always does there's almost no
time when you can't do a story about
corruption but today it still seems
incredibly resonant and maybe from my
perspective maybe more so than maybe at
other times so it does look like the
film will have a political aspect to it
we know that Peter Sarsgaard is playing
a corrupt da known as Gil Coulson and
that he'll be an out-and-out liar
we know that the Riddler has a victim
that has no more lies written on a mask
across his face so it is possible that
they are one in the same I think it
would be really interesting to see
Riddler as a vigilante similar to Batman
where both wished to take down corrupt
members of Gotham
however the villain is more extreme and
therefore they could really explore the
differences between the two villains and
heroes are always way more interesting
when their opposite sides of the same
coin and I think it would be a brilliant
way to discuss the dichotomy of a killer
and a hero now before we get into the
rest of the video in which we discuss
Reeves his thoughts on Tim Burton and
Christopher Nolan I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the interview
in the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
April and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever get to the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay so that wasn't the only
interview that Reeves did and in another
with the Nerdist the director discussed
how he viewed Batman and his abilities
he opened it by saying I just felt like
well what I'd love to do is get a
version of this Batman character where
he's not yet fully formed where there's
something to do in this context with who
that guy would be in this world today
and to ground him in all of these broken
ways so does indeed seem that we are
getting a pretty basic Batman that
still finding his feet and we do know
that this has been reflected in the
Batmobile and bat bike which both look
like they've been made by the character
himself Batman of course comes with a
large legacy that looms over him and
when approaching a new film one has to
acknowledge the work that came before
Reeves is no stranger to this and he too
gave his thought on Nolan and Burton's
work when discussing them he said I
thought well there's been some terrific
Batman movies and I don't want to be
part of a long line of Batman movies
where this is just another one I feel
like they've been really distinctive the
best ones have been incredible what
Nolan did was incredible what Tim Burton
did was really singular I loved Batman
Returns Michelle Pfeiffer was incredible
I love it I love it so much it's so
incredible and she's so incredible in it
I just think it's such a beautiful movie
I loved the Penguins stuff when he's
going down the sewers as a baby it's
just like wow this is the beautiful
thing about Tim Burton that is best in
that way that he's got that connection
to the fantastical that feels very very
personal he went on further to say The
Dark Knight is so incredible and I think
that Heath Ledger's performance and
their conception of the Joker in that
movie is indelible a definitely thing
you men to say incredible there but you
just decided to change your last minute
anime and that battle that he engaged
with you you know Batman / Bruce is
incredible they were go the incredible
again but the thing that you take away
from it more than anything is that
conception specifically I think of the
Joker that movie is so much about how
it's a horrifying thing to stare into
the abyss that idea of that level of
nihilism the whole idea that there was
nothing you could do because even in the
destruction of him you are fulfilling
his aims it was just a terrifying notion
that speaks to an aspect of human nature
and that was really profound so he
clearly has a lot of love and
appreciation for the character and there
are definitely a number of things from
this interview that indicate he's going
towards a darker version of the
character I think that's what people
enjoy best with the Batman and with
Joker redefining the character last year
and changing what it meant to be a comic
book movie I think we are in for a real
treat going forward with the upcoming DC
projects
hopefully the days won't hold its
release
can imagine that Reeves is working hard
right now to iron out all of the kinks
within the movie so we get the best
version of its vision possible now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these updates and what you want to
see in the next couple of weeks I'm
gonna be keeping my eyes close to the
updates and if any big news comes out
then you'll definitely be the first to
hear it
make sure you stay luck to the channel
and please give us a thumbs up if you
enjoyed the video if you want something
else to watch after this then make sure
you check out our full breakdown of Zack
Snyder's original plan for the DC EU we
go over everything from Man of Steel all
the way up to Justice League part 3 so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from is a little is
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
yeah access to content early and can
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made if you want to come chat to us
after the show in the follow us at
Definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep everything with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition and you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]